things you dreamed about you don't think
are happening well it happened and like
it's just amazing and we're just just
trying to hold on to as long as we can't
man be honest with you because uh it's a
special feeling living his best life
right now Mitchell's gained a ton of
buzz from his major label debut telling
all my secrets
[Music]
you
not to mention he's one-half of
country's newest power couple with
girlfriend Canadian country star Megan
Patrick you're on the road in any
relationship and they're making you feel
guilty about your dream it's not right
when I found Megan that never happened
it was instantly I'm rooting for her
she's rooting for me we miss each other
like crazy we had a dream before we knew
each other and that's why we love each
other so much like I'm so proud I'm so
inspired by her and this Nashville
native inspires his ladylove to Megan
confessed to us that her latest ballad
wild as me it's all about their love I
wrote it with two of his best friends it
was one of those times where like we
knew we had something special as soon as
we finished the song and we played it
for him and I think he was kind of
taking it back used like nobody's really
ever written the song about
[Music]
when I heard that one in some of the
specific things about it I knew I knew
she'd channel a little bit of our
relationship in that and you know I
broke down in my truck and I was driving
around the first time she said and I was
you know you can leave in a ride and she
said baby I wrote this song about you
and I just I mean that's the greatest
feeling in the world
[Music]